hello
my name is kevin hemphill and i'm an r d
scientist
at horizon discovery today i will be
presenting some work
showing our successful synthesis and
validation
of a long chemically modified ms2 guide
rna
for use in crispr applications such as
the crispr activation
sam system using synthetic guides for
crispr activation studies
can be especially beneficial for either
individual
hit validation or raid screening with no
cloning
sequencing or in vitro transcription
required
to begin with a brief overview crispr
activation
is a repurposing of the crispr cast
system where a dead
or deactivated cas9 is brought to a
transcriptional start site by a guide
rna complex
consisting of the crisp rna and the
tracer rna
in addition transcriptional activators
are brought to this dna target site
either through fusion with dcas9 alone
in the case of the vpr activation system
or through fusion with dcas9 and an ms2
code protein
in the case of the sam activation system
in order to
bring this ms2 coat protein activator
fusion
to the start site ms2 aftomer sequences
must be incorporated
into the guide rna previously the system
has relied on guides
containing two ms2 optomers and have
been expressed either as plasmid or
through lentiviral integration
because of the added ms2 sequence
requirements chemically synthesized
guides of this length
have been hard to produce at horizon
discovery we have used chemistries and
processes
developed over decades of research for
the efficient
cost effective and high throughput
synthesis of guide rnas
containing either one or two ms2
optomers
at different regions of the crispr rna
and tracernate complex
we found that a tracer rna containing
just one ms2 optomer
on the second stem loop is able to
produce the highest level of
transcriptional activation
when used with crispr a crispr rna in
the same system
we have validated this 104 nucleotide
long
ms2 tracer rna or sam trace rna
both through uplc and mass spec analyses
for a 70 micromole synthesis scale we
are able to obtain the full length
product
containing the desired target mass and
with high purity
in order to then functionally validate
this new guide rna
we transfected the sam trace rna and
various ms2 trace rna designs
with the crispr a crispr rna targeting
transcriptional start sites
for several genes of interest
gene activation was measured by rtq-pcr
and can also be assessed by western
blots and immunofluorescence analysis
we measure gene activation for six
different gene targets across several
cell
lines stably expressing the activation
complex components of the same
system and saw that crispr rna complexed
with the same trace rna
were able to achieve very high levels of
transcriptional fold activation
for targets that have low endogenous
gene expression levels
such as titan we were able to achieve
between 1
and 10 000 fold activation while targets
that tend to have
higher endogenous expression levels such
as egfr
we were still able to see over 15-fold
levels of activation
we next compared activation levels
resulting from the synthetic guide
system
to the currently available 2 by ms2
guides
that are expressed either as plasmid or
through lentiviral integration
we tested three different gene targets
for activation in a few cell lines
and saw that this synthetic guide
approach with one aptomer
actually produces similar or in some
cases higher levels of activation
than the expressed guides we then
took our analysis a step further by
pooling together
multiple crispr rnas with the samtras
rna before transfecting into cells
these added r crispr a crispr rnas
incorporate the weizmann lab algorithm
that take into account chromatin
position
and sequence features to accurately
predict highly effective dna target
sites
we see that by providing multiple of
these crispr rnas
to the same target gene we can further
enhance transcriptional activation
levels
as a final validation step we compared
activation
of six gene targets with crispr rna and
sam tracer rna
in cells stably expressing the sam
system
versus crispr rna complex with irregular
no ms2 containing tracer rna
in cells stably expressing the bpr
system another
of the major second generation crispry
systems
we saw that activation levels tend to be
fairly similar in both systems and only
vary slightly depending on gene target
in conclusion we have been able to
successfully synthesize
and validate a long chemically modified
ms2 guide rna
for use in the crispr a sam system we
have also demonstrated
the power of using synthetic guides for
crispr a
which can be especially beneficial for
either individual hip validation
or a raid screening with no cloning
sequencing
or in vitro transcription required
you